[Music]
it's nine o'clock this is sky news
welcome to our show where i interview
people who have something to say about
the world today and how it's changing
they'll be from politics sport business
entertainment public life or they'll be
everyday people caught up in the events
of our times i'll be putting my
questions to tonight's special guests
[Music]
good evening educational under
achievement and the challenge of opening
up social opportunities for young people
there are no high priorities when it
comes to governing back to basics in the
classroom is popular among parents but
does it hold the key to opening up
social mobility the government seem to
think so because they've given catherine
burble singh known as britain's
strictest headmistress the job of
improving social mobility for the poor
but are we prepared to learn her lessons
also ahead the u.s political landscape
has changed dramatically from the obama
administration to the trump era and now
under president biden their
administrations have been shaped by a
global financial crisis and then the
coveted pandemic author michael lewis's
critically acclaimed books tackle some
of the biggest moments in american
history his work has been turned into
hollywood films and now a netflix series
created by the obama's production
company could his books now act as a
warning for future generations
and dame emma thompson has had a career
spanning 40 years most known for her
roles in sense and sensibility love
actually harry potter and howard's end
to name but a few she's now talking on
her sexiest role yet addressing the
hurdles faced by older women who want a
healthy sex life emma and her co-star
daryl mccormack talk to me about sex and
why protecting the younger generations
from the prevalence of the porn industry
is so important
catherine barbelsing is the new chair of
the social mobility commission in her
inaugural speech today she said that
britain is too focused on the rags to
rich's dream and people in the poorest
parts of society do not need to aim for
an oxbridge education
catherine's also known as britain's
strictest headmistress leading a school
called the michaela community school in
a deprived area of london her methods
are often seen to be controversial i
spoke to her a short time ago
catherine thanks for joining us on the
show today uh today you set out your
vision for britain and social mobility
or the government's new social
mobilities are but before we get on to
all of that um i wanted to talk to you
about education because for viewers that
don't know you you are branded now as
the country's strictest head teacher i
don't know if you love or loathe that or
just find it a bit
amusing but but let's start off about
talking about uh education there was a
documentary on itv uh about you and your
school
um and at the start of this documentary
one of your colleagues says it's not
like north korea
but those
unused to your beliefs about education
might think it did look a bit like north
korea so can you can you explain to the
viewers why it's not
because the place is just filled with
love you know the children are happy
that staff are happy the staff love
seeing the children
i see them for assembly every single day
in fact i do seven assemblies a week you
know because we've got seven year groups
um there's just a real sense of purpose
we all know why we're there we're there
because we want to achieve and give the
children the skills and knowledge that
they need to be able to make the most of
their lives and to enable social
mobility for our children because we're
in the inner city with children coming
from a variety of different backgrounds
and um we want to give them the best
chances that they can have in life
really and and just
you know if people that haven't seen the
documentary or know about your school i
mean it is really strict so there's no
talking in corridors i think there's a
line along the corridor yeah uh if you
drop your pencil you get a detention uh
well
not if you not now if you were to not
bring your pen in you would get a
detention um you're dropping your pencil
that's fine that's fine but but i'm
trying to get across this it's really
really strict and it's unusually strict
compared perhaps with other uh state
schools why'd you do it like that yeah
well the thing about strict is that
people tend to think that must mean that
you're mean but actually i would say
that it means you love the children
enough to keep your standards high for
them so the pen is a good example you
need to bring a pen into school um
they're all taught to make sure that
they're packing their bags the night
before they've all got the same pencil
case with the same pens so there's real
consistency and those same pens are
expected for five years so they have two
black pens a blue pen a 2b pencil
they've got and they know exactly what
they need to be in there so
in that sense it's relatively
straightforward but then even if they do
forget it some of the children run a
little shop in the morning where they
sell pens for 10p so you can always pick
up a pen in the morning
if you're if you've forgotten it
and catherine what do you do with kids
that
can't do it or won't do it or do you
believe that it isn't that kids can't do
this
they can can't adhere to your rules i
mean i mean they they all manage it
the key thing is to remember that um
children have agency and they can choose
whether or not they want to do something
what do you do with kids
what do you do with kids with special
education needs or kids with adhd kids
that might not be able
because of their own issues to focus in
the way that you require them to focus
in class do you have separate rules for
them or do those children have to
conform or do they not fit into the
school well we have a normal intake of
inner city children so we have a variety
of children with different issues i
would say i mean there are a few
children you might need to slightly
adapt for but
i would say that too often we allow
labels to force us to lower our
expectations of children um and that
they could achieve a lot more if we just
allowed ourselves to believe in them
despite the fact that they might
struggle so if they struggle in
something you might have to give them
some support in getting there to be able
to meet those standards some children
don't require much support and some
children require more support
um
but the key thing is to believe that
they can do it there has been
a sense from others in the teaching
community that you're kind of implicitly
criticizing uh other teachers or other
schools that do it differently to you
what do you say to that catherine
well if you're you can do things however
much you like as long as you're doing
right by the children i mean what i mean
is uh do you go to the school and visit
and think the children are well behaved
they're learning lots have they got
great gcse results are the children
happy are they loved if that's the case
then brilliant
but if that's not the case
then well we ought to be critical of
those schools shouldn't we i mean
shouldn't we as a society say that's not
good enough come on you've got to do
better now the thing is there are some
schools in genuine difficulty that are
trying very hard to get better and
that's brilliant but there are other
schools that are ideological in their
position that don't want to change
because
they don't believe
that children can do better what do you
mean by that ideological in their
position well for instance they would
find uh our strict rules um
offensive they don't like that idea
but then if it's pointed out that but
look
there's lots of chaos here in this
school perhaps it would be better if you
had more rules they don't want to do
that and i would be critical of that you
know you spoke at the 2010 conservative
party conference and you became kind of
an emblem if you like of traditional
ways of teaching i mean some of your
fellow teachers make this point about
you when they're asked about you that
you're an excellent teacher clearly with
great ideas to offer
but you have become sometimes like a
weapon in a culture war in which what
you've just said about different methods
of teaching that other parents or
teachers might like somehow you're
critical of those and and that becomes a
culture war
what do you think about that do you do
you
disagree with that or do you not mind or
do you think it's okay
well i think it's
i think that we all need to have high
standards for all of our children and
there are children
right now
in classrooms with very poor behavior
who aren't able to learn and i'm the
chair of the social mobility commission
i believe very much in social mobility
for all of our children and if there are
children who aren't able to be upwardly
mobile because of the poor behavior in
their classrooms then that's something i
need to be critical about what i've read
about you and what i've seen about you
in terms of your teaching you stress the
importance of adults modeling standards
and behavior for children that's a
really important value for you
do you think the prime minister is a
good role model for children
no i do not think so
um
i don't uh
i wish he could be but he isn't um and
that is a bit sad but um you know
i i can't get into the ins and outs
because i don't know enough about um
you know people say you know will she be
there should he not be there i don't
know you know uh i don't i i like boris
i don't think he's a bad guy you know um
but i don't
i don't know enough about what he's got
up to but i do not think that he's a
good role model for children what's not
good about him in what way
well his personal life for instance um
uh
that that does make me sort of raise an
eyebrow um
his hair
how can i say his hair we've got strict
rules at school you know the other day i
saw a picture of him in the metro and i
looked at his hair and i thought oh my
goodness you know we expect our children
to have professional looking hair and i
looked at his hair and i thought gosh i
couldn't put him up on the wall and say
let's all have haircuts like him um now
you might think oh that's a bit pedantic
and that's a bit silly
but it isn't actually i think for our
children um
it's important to
uh look professional
and
sometimes boris looks professional but
sometimes he's not professional enough
for me let me put it that way okay so
family values because that's a small
secret family values exactly it's the
sort of thing that makes me pause a
little bit now and that's not to say
he just you know and actually i i'd say
i'm i'm relatively liberal about these
things to a certain extent you know but
he does kind of push the boat out a bit
on that own character
well and that's where you start and as i
said i don't know the ins and outs
enough about all the recent partygate
stuff you know i just don't know the
details because i'm too busy working to
follow all of that but
but it does sort of make you pause and
go
you know i certainly would never be able
to put him up and say be like him i
couldn't do that
look you just did a speech on social
mobility you talked about a fresh
approach i listened to it and at the
heart of it it seemed to me
that your approach is driven through a
combination of sort of spreading
opportunity more across the country and
an individual's own agency to kind of
change their lives rather than talking
about sort of structures holding people
back and structural inequalities that is
that fair interpretation of what your
approach will be in this job
yeah um the thing is is that we want to
look at people who are backing the
trends how is it that in an unequal
society that some people are are
upwardly mobile what do they do to
achieve that and um
so we want to look at them we also want
to look at uh
the ideas around what happens to the
many as opposed to the few often i think
as a society we are pushed um to look at
the people who start at the bottom and
then zoom to the top and it makes a
great hollywood film
it's romantic it's wonderful look i grew
up with nothing and now i'm this big ceo
and i eat expensive dinners but not all
of us necessarily want to do that and
some of us want to have shorter
mobilities and
it would be wrong for instance someone
comes from a
home that's unemployed lots of
unemployment and then they become a
manager at sainsbury's well isn't that
something to celebrate but often we
don't necessarily celebrate these the
these smaller achievements because we
only see the huge leap um as as the
success story and um
we would like to change the narrative
around that really
going on to that idea about the sort of
success being defined as i think you
said a sort of caretaker's daughter
ending up in
oxbridge
and it actually being success defined as
someone whose parents are unemployed and
then have been long-term unemployed and
then they get a job that that is their
version of social mobility that maybe
oxford is too much but becoming a
manager at sainsbury's is not right and
different people want to do different
things but of course we've got children
at school who are going to oxbridge and
it's really exciting and we're 100
behind that so you don't want to stop
doing that but not everyone can go to
oxbridge that's all but
one thing i did want to ask you though
because i think you went to oxford
didn't you yeah um because when it comes
to oxbridge the higher education
minister said recently that those
universities shouldn't discriminate
against private school students going to
oxbridge that those organizers tilted
too much and they're too focused on
getting more state school kids in what's
your view of that
yeah i don't know to be honest i don't
know how much they're tilting one way or
the other it is important that um
the the places that everyone wants to
get into whether it's the big law firms
or it's oxbridge and so on it's
important that they
recognize that they can get talent from
all different types of places and
they're not just coming from the private
sector or they're just not coming from
the state sector so they need to keep an
open mind and that's good but from my
point of view i'm thinking about how can
we make sure it's chair as the
commission how can we make sure as many
people as possible
are enabled to be able to make a success
of their lives finding a career that
they love which will give them purpose
and satisfaction because not all of us
want to be prime minister not always not
all of us want to be millionaires and
that's good i mean you're not prime
minister and you're very happy doing
your job you know
like that's the thing all of us want to
do different things i love being a
teacher i love being at school with the
children so
we all need to do what gives us it makes
us passionate you know what would you
like to do in the future i mean you've
you know you're extremely successful
professional in teaching you've now got
a public sector role advising the
government on social mobility is
politics something you might want to do
one day no never i mean in fact i feel
bad as chatting about boris because at
the end of the day he's just a man and
he's taken on a role that i would never
do and i would never do it because i
wouldn't want people sitting on on on a
television program chatting about me in
this way and yet in that sense he has
sacrificed you know and given over his
life
but if you did do it you could implement
your school model across the entire
country no
no that's the thing you need to win
people's hearts and minds you can't do
that in fact in many ways you're very
powerless as prime minister um
i think we misunderstand just how much
power our prime minister actually has
catherine thank you so much that was
fascinating thanks for coming on thank
you
and if you scan this qr code on your
screen right now you can watch all of
our interviews online and all of the
previous episodes of the show if you'd
like to
well stay with us because coming up next
i'll be talking to dame emma thompson
and her co-star darryl mccormack
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
well there's a real sense now that
people are beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate
we saw snatchbots going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover
or you die
okay so that's like a wall that's the
war yeah
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
[Music]
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united states
would become hooked
[Music]
enormous explosion it's just come down i
think it was a monster just landed in
between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in iraq and
syria but across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
withdrawing so so hot
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
[Music]
welcome back one of britain's leading
ladies for four decades actor comedian
writer and at times a political
campaigner emma thompson has always been
unafraid of facing taboos and now she
deals with a big one in her new film
good luck to you leo grande but i was
also keen to ask her about the
government's plan to send asylum seekers
to rwanda not least because she has an
adopted son who was a refugee from that
country i met her and darren mccormack
earlier can we start off
with the film because
it's a film about
the sexuality of middle aged women
in many ways and about compassion too
but
and you've been in the business for a
long long time do you think a script
like this could have been would have
been even written five or ten years ago
maybe five years ago but ten years ago
probably not actually i think it's a
very good question because
um even though things have been changing
and there are more interesting things
for women don't forget you know five
years ago mindy kaling wrote late night
which is about a
female talk show host which has never
been seen on screen before never been
thought about which is actually when you
think about it completely mad
completely mad
why isn't there
a female talk show host that's
what because women can't talk um
no does not compute everybody it's just
crazy anyway when they have interesting
personalities and are fun
i so
um but what's sort of original about it
is
is the encounter itself and the fact
that it's about
so many things it is about female
sexuality of course but it's about
sexual pleasure and shame across the
board
and about you know the possible kind of
sanctity of sex work as well
for 31 years my husband would climb on
top do the business roll off put his
pajamas on and go back to sleep
i've never had an orgasm
and yes in fact if we do this
you will only be the second man i have
ever had sex with
oh god no nancy this is crazy that's
terrible it's wrong nancy yes let's go
to bed okay
it really does cover so much it doesn't
you're right about the middle age thing
you know i really enjoyed it because i
thought it spoke to an audience that
sometimes isn't spoken to or off
and um it seemed to me as well it was
sort of correct and an imbalance in that
the is of often besotted with sort of
young women and treating them in as
sexual beings and a man sexy at any age
and then women
as they get older they sort of disappear
like sexually they disappear well it
would be a pretty big thing to try and
counteract with one acting role in a
film um so yeah i try not to think about
the sort of global implications of my
work while i'm acting something i'm just
trying to make it as truthful as
possible whether it does uh have that
effect it would be lovely but um i don't
think about it in those universal terms
it's interesting to talk about it
afterwards but what i was
was drawn to was
this woman who'd um really ticked all
the boxes i think this is the
interesting thing that there are lots of
shapes that we invited to get into and i
think i mean dazzle say you know men as
well this is what you should be women in
particular because they don't have as
much freedom like it or not everyone
said oh no we've done all that no we
haven't so
accept that because we haven't done it
yet you know women are not as free as
men to do what they want they're simply
not and so nancy's um
admissions about the
limitations of her life and the
limitations of what she's experienced a
very painful did you feel sorry for
nancy i mean meeting when you meet your
fourth meeting she says you're the only
adventurer i've ever had the only
freedom and then in the fast meeting you
know she says she tells you i've never
had an orgasm i've i've never had all
sets did you both
when you read the switch did you think
poor nancy
did you think poor nancy i i'm not
particularly because i think we come
from a similar place where i felt i i
thought it was incredible that she was
making this choice for herself that she
was taking this autonomy yeah to go and
seek this experience
you know kind of at her age as well and
and at the experience that she's been
given prior to this moment so
i never felt
um poor nancy i thought wow the kind of
scope of the experience that she's going
through and and the vulnerability that
she's walking through to get there yeah
i thought was quite incredible to see so
you know i think i i never tried to have
an emotional take on where they were
coming from i just was fascinated by the
difference in their walks of life and
what they were both going through i do
feel
the tragedy of her
you know get at 16 sort of nearly having
access to her sexuality and then it
being somehow taken away and then she
goes and does array levels and goes to
teacher training and becomes a teacher
and gets married and does all the things
right and does everything right does
everything right
and never ever
returns or never continues that journey
because as she says you know she was
pretty much living in the 50s but to be
honest with you beth i don't think that
that female pleasure
is at the top of anybody's to do kind of
list
i've never done anything interesting or
remarkable in my life
this is it i see my friends shriveling
up over the years
i'm sorry nancy everyone needs something
different i don't judge my clients
unless they're totally hair souls it
also seemed to me
that
for nancy she grew up in a world as you
said where female pleasure was not
something discussed in fact if anything
female sexuality was almost a taboo
do you think that'd be an
intergenerational difference where
younger women might watch this film and
go oh my god my poor mother aunt grandma
is that what they had to put up with and
they won't relate to it because they're
like that's not how we live now we're
empowered sexually
but we i talked to lots of young women
about this and many quite a few of them
said to me i didn't even know about
masturbation until i was in my twenties
you know we think
that this revolution has occurred well
because young women 22 23 years old that
surprises me actually well
here we are we're here to be surprised
aren't we because we live in london and
we've lived in you know this sort of
rather metropolitan cosmopolitan world
where people have access to all sorts of
things and read cosmopolitan which sort
of suggests that if you haven't had an
orgasm in the last 15 minutes you're not
truly alive you know which is a form of
i think a kind of bullying you know if
you're not emerging
fantastic yeah you're right
just sort of yes
just having spontaneous orgasms
at westminster you know because that's
like you're just
in it and there you know as if it's an
easy thing to achieve
but i think i i
i
i think we
we're very dishonest
about sex and i think we're often very
dishonest about how much
we're actually enjoying it to be honest
well actually that's one thing i really
liked film was about it kind of picked
up on the sort of awkwardness and
weirdness of sex sometimes as well
didn't it
between the two characters
i just want to ask someone about it
there was a there's there's a bit of a
a dark moment i thought in the film
when nancy gets quite upset
with leo because he's sort of saying
well you might want more sessions and
it's really because he's saying you
might you actually just need to talk to
me and then she says i'm paying you for
a service i don't have my just get on
with it and it kind of
it it makes it really transaction
because you forget that this is a
transaction
there's a danger in the film could you
imagine if you did the exact same film
but the genders of the protagonists were
reversed it becomes more sinister so it
becomes this you could make this film
and reverse the gender you could you
simply couldn't make it
because the playing field is not level
it
it just wouldn't make any sense
there's nothing to explore there or
there's other things to explore but they
would be very very different i just want
to ask you one other thing on that
ageism it's still a prejudice that sort
of seems permissible in society and for
older women they often suffer a sort of
double prejudice because you're too old
for
roles you're too old to have sex you're
too old to even be seen anymore is that
something you feel strongly about or as
you get older do you feel it's changing
well i'm
i've been very lucky because young women
like katie and mindy have written things
for me that are completely not haven't
been seen before which says two things
first of all i don't feel invisible
and second of all there's
change
because young women don't just want to
write films about young women they want
to write films about all female
experience and also because katie was
interested in writing something about a
young man
and young men's experience which is i
think
quite hard yeah i think it's interesting
about the i think katie did a really
good job you know there's something
interesting about leo in the context
that he is in a professional environment
so we don't really get to see much of
his inner life but i think it's it's i'm
really grateful k did know that he is
also going through his own journey with
regards to sexuality with regards to
kind of um body image at some point as
well but i think
that's the reason why he's able to be
here and lay this foundation because i
think he's gone through his own
experience so i think i hope even though
it's not as
fleshed out i think
there is an element there where you know
the that young men will also go through
their own version i think that's what is
universal about this is that we do have
to look at that journey for ourselves
daryl when you were born emma was
already a major thing right she's a
major star was it weird to be cast in a
romantic relationship
the oscars are usually in january right
yes that's right so i was born in
january 93 that was the year you won
yourself that's right that's right and
then you're in a romantic relationship
how was that incredible
it's not incredible i think that's i
mean that's that's amazing that this job
that we do that you can really just be
completely there and you can really
share environments like this it's so
funny
isn't it actually i haven't thought
about it like that and so
isn't it the generation generationally
you asked beth earlier which is which is
very interesting i think that
there's abs it's absolutely
true that my mother's generation
um had a completely different entry into
sort of sexual life to my generation and
you're younger than me but you know 60s
70s i was born in 59 and then my
daughter's generation those three
generations of women it'd be very
interesting to do something about yeah
the three but it's got better for your
daughter
i hope so i mean i think some things of
i think some things are worse when i
hear stories in
schools about boys and what they expect
from girls and
oh well
i mean that the easy access to porn you
know if you talk to young people about
their sexual knowledge and what they
expect and what they think sex is it can
be very disturbing indeed and i think
can interfere with their sexual
development because it's all been taken
away industrialized and fed back to them
in a sort of completely
kind of unindigestible form
you know um so so i think that there are
uh pressures
outside i also think that the sexual
revolution is a very complex
um
issue it's not like we had that and then
everything was better and now young
people it's all better it's never like
that in human experience we we take a
step forward and then we tie ourselves
into weird knots because the fact of the
matter is we have no respect at all for
our sexual desires
we ridicule them we
we make them the butt of our jokes we we
don't respect
what
our desires are and we find when they're
odd which they often are we find them
shameful and ridiculous i just wanted to
ask you finally there's a major refugee
crisis in europe you've spoken about
refugee causes
your own adopted son i think was it was
a refugee
do you think we're doing enough at the
moment
for refugees
and for ukraine no but i mean you know
refugees across the board the real
problem is our sort of referral
mechanisms are a mess and the rwanda
scheme is
um
sort of eye-wateringly mad and um
callous
you know we're exhibiting a callousness
as a callousness in government that i
don't think reflects
the soul of this country and the nature
of the people in this country i really
don't
um i understand that that
uh
you know a lot of refugees will be
thinking well it's all you know all the
ukrainians are white and this kind of
welcome wasn't given to syrian refugees
when the same sort of thing was
happening in aleppo and all that and i
understand that too but at the same time
there's been a huge compassionate
opening of of british people
people in this country have all wanted
to help so so much and been um
really severely uh prevented from doing
so by government mechanisms and
all sorts of
internal difficulties with things like
bank accounts and
not our civil society not somehow being
helped to rise to the occasion i mean
this is a very very complex issue but
the movement of peoples not only due to
war but due to climate change is going
to be the most one of the biggest issues
of our time and certainly of the 21st
century and we better start getting our
minds around
how people need to move and we'll have
we will have to accept that we can't
become fortresses we can't put up walls
anymore it's not realistic we've run out
of time but maybe one day we could do
another interview together you know
we'll do more political ones yeah well
look thank you so much thanks for thanks
for uh spending some time talking to me
and congratulations on the film
which i'm going to force everyone i know
to watch that's brilliant i like the
word force yeah i think that's good
i mean i'm now an empowered middle-aged
woman and i'm going to force everyone
emma thompson they're breaking so many
taboos well stay with us because coming
up next i'll be joined by the author of
the premonition and the fifth risk
michael lewis
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
we support communities to grow food in
lost and unloved spaces across the city
so our main kind of driving force is to
get people growing
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back what can we learn from the
last two years living in a global
pandemic michael lewis is a best-selling
author of the fifth risk the big short a
money ball his latest book the
premonition looks at the official
response to the covered outbreak by the
u.s administration i spoke to him
earlier
michael thanks so much uh for coming on
the show um i've read lots of your books
and it's really really great to meet you
so thanks for coming on and
i want to start with um
the fifth wrist which is a political
journalist i have to say i found
absolutely fascinating it's this story
of the transition from obama to trump
and basically what a mess it was um
trump resistance to even having a
transition
team hundreds of posts uh left empty but
before we get into the book and what
it's about and also been making into a
tv series can you explain to the viewers
what does the fifth uh what does the
fifth risk actually mean well the title
comes from a conversation i had with
someone who was managing existential
risks in part of the u.s government and
i was just asking him
like what are the top five risks that
you worry about in your little
department the department of energy so
i'm worried about nuclear weapons going
off when they shouldn't go off and we
spend a lot of time thinking about that
or are not going off if we need them to
go off uh you know i'm worried about the
iran the iran nuclear deal because we're
in the middle of that so he's listing
and he gets to five
and when he gets to the fifth one
it's such a boris boring sounding one
but it ended up being right at the
center of the story i was telling it and
he said it's he says the fifth risk i'm
going to call it program management and
with it what i mean by that is
there are these risks that the united
states government are managing that are
inter they go through for generations
they're long-term risks
and that if we take our eye off the ball
catastrophic things can happen and there
are these things throughout the federal
government so when i thought called the
fifth i was thinking like
these are the risks you as a citizen
are oblivious to you're just taking it
for granted that your government is
handling it in some way more or less
competently at the same time you
yourself probably think very little of
your government because you're an
american and americans have been trained
to hate their government what happens if
this goes wrong
uh and the so the book that was that was
kind of a starting point for them there
is the fifth risk there are all these uh
risks within government and then
president trump is elected
who it tells you a lot about the state
of our society right that and
so by law the outgoing administration in
that case the obama administration is
required to prepare briefings for the
income administration because our
government unlike yours is is managed by
presidential appointees not career civil
servants so
4 000
plus people are going to roll in with a
new president and they're going to have
to be you know appointed by him and
confirmed by the senate to run all these
different agencies okay let me ask you
another question because viewers here
might think in the uk might think
trump's it's done it's over there's
abide and it's a new era but how worried
are you about trump coming back and
becoming the president again in 2020 i
wouldn't like it
are you worried about do you think it's
a possibility of course it's a
possibility and of course it's
unpredictable if you ask me to put um
odds on it
i'd say five to one against i don't
think it's the likely outcome why
because you think the republicans will
rely on different candidates
yes i do
and i think um
he's not good at being president
i mean he didn't there
if he had been run it you know like a
half decent pandemic response he'd still
be president that his incompetence ends
up being a big issue and
we're going to come onto
but before i do just quickly because the
thing also about the fifth wrist i mean
everyone should read it i actually
listened to it on a pod i listened to
the audio book um but also it's been
made into a um netflix drama right just
came out yeah i said yeah right by the
bar the obama production company yes so
how did that come about had they got uh
why did the obamas want to televise a um
a book about
that's so critical of trump is there any
gender there no i tell you what's funny
about it
you would think it sounds the way you
just put that obama saw an anti-trump
thing yeah and thought oh put that on
that is what i thought it's the the
opposite that they've been bending over
backwards the obamas to avoid engaging
in the in any kind of political overt
political kind of messaging activity
what attracted obama you know so it
counted against the book
that um it had this kind of
anti-trump
undertone uh would appeal to him about
it was it was the first
attempt to really describe what the hell
the government did you know like this
this these exist this management of
existential risks that nobody knew about
he really liked the idea of basically
delivering an entertaining civics lesson
i thought maybe part of the obama's
motivation
for televising this was to actually kind
of send a warning to america as they saw
it of don't make the same mistake twice
guys if this man runs in 2024 but that
wasn't it was a different warning it was
the delivery it was the warning was you
neglect this government that you have
at your peril what's he like what's it
like doing a project with him
well i i met him because i wrote about
him i wrote a big piece for vanity fair
years ago and i kind of moved into his
life in the white house when he was
president and got to know him a bit then
in some ways a very unlikely politician
in that
he's you don't feel like you're with a
politician you feel like you know what
he's
he's got the he's got the temperament
the personality of a writer fun to be
with i was very fond of him i mean
interesting guy
i
i
i think i told him once it may have
offended him that
um
if he was not black i don't think he'd
have been president because the fact
that he was black disguised people
disguised just how
unpolitical he was unlike a politician
he was
um
that how
how
peculiar he was
and it the truth is that this man would
never have been a politician if he had a
successful literary career he started
out wanting to write short stories and
they didn't get accepted
and i think so i think he's like a
writer who stumbled into politics and
found found a calling
um
but you miss you do mistake him if you
think like the reason he grabbed my book
was it was a way to needle donald trump
it was the opposite he told the
producers that leave trump to one side
this isn't about trump they didn't
listen to him completely of course but
how could you one thing that really
astonished me in the book is the moment
where you say uh trump finds out he's
won pennsylvania's called and then karen
pence goes to hug mike pence the vice
president or so mike goes to hart caron
and and sort of for congratulatory hug
she kind of pushes him away so something
like you've got what what she you got
what you want she was offended by him
offended by who mike pence or donald
trump or both of them donald trump and
mike pence's pence's allegiance to him
at that moment you got what you wanted
mike leave me alone i mean you got to
remember this is uh
these are
these are
she's a good christian lady from middle
america and donald trump is violating
everything she believes in left and
right
and uh i think she was offended by him
i've never heard her say that but that
was i i interviewed people who watched
that encounter and so who knows exactly
what was going on in her head let's go
on to um
about the pandemic the pandemic book the
premonition
um
you talk about that um about the what
happened in the u.s it was a uk for us
it was a traumatic experience to 180 000
deaths here in the u.s with a much
bigger population of course a million
deaths in your book you say a miracle
the west developed the tools to defeat
to pandemic but america didn't implement
those tools
what do you mean by that was that a
trump problem
or a us government problem it's the most
remarkable story we both share and we
kind of both share the story
there was a study in 2019 done at great
expense millions of dollars hundreds of
experts to determine this before the
pandemic which countries on the planet
were best equipped to deal with a
pandemic like who had the resources who
were who was who is going to respond
best
the united states came out number one in
the uk came out number two
so we in theory are best prepared for
this in practice our death rates were
off the charts i mean we're kind of like
i don't know where the u.s is now but we
were 120th somewhere down there you know
yemen out performs this kind of thing
and so that was what the beginning what
interested me is like what happened have
you come up with the conclusion that we
would be better or worse equipped to
cope with a
another pandemic as the result of the
covert experience
we as a world or we as a united states
well let's do both so we as the united
states are clearly worse off
why um because
there's not only no agreement
on what we did right and what we did
wrong
there's active disagreement and 40 of
the country won't get vaccinated 40 of
the country thinks that the social
interventions were
pointless but but it would be hard it
would be harder to lead the country but
michael is that not just partly also not
about the sort of
about the who was in power i mean you
know some of the disinformation i
remember watching that press conference
agog as donald trump said you know what
we could do i remember you know we could
um inject disinfectant as a corona
corona fights remember i remember i was
watching and then dr bridge this sort of
standard the camera pans to the
i mean the thing was ludicrous but there
was a very serious point in that which
is if a leader
shares
disinformation then the anti-vaxxers and
and people stop believing in the in the
process i mean presumably under a
different leadership it might be better
for the us if there was a point
that would be true would have been true
had there been different leadership the
first time we went through this and they
could people who could have been led and
so instead of 40 of the population
revolting against the right thing to do
would have been 20
um but now they've revolted and dug in
their heels they're harder they'll be
much harder persua persuade i mean there
will be a assist if there were right now
if a more lethal pathogen swept across
the united states there would be an
instinctive and well organized
resistance to doing anything to defend
ourselves michael just
just before we end
i hope you don't mind me asking you
about this as as you were writing the
book on covid and what was going on your
own family experienced an unbearable
tragedy your daughter i hope you don't
mind me asking you about her your
daughter dixie um died in a car crash
right as the book was coming out
um
and
it's been the hardest year of my life
she was she was 19 she was with her
boyfriend ross who was a year older ross
schultz and they
drove in
broad daylight head on into a truck and
um it makes one aware of a few things
very quickly
one how precious life is
and uh two how it can change in a
heartbeat
and three
the
the amazing
thing to me right away
was i'd never had i've never had that
this kind of grief i've never
experienced this kind of loss my parents
are still alive and flourishing
and
instantly
i was admitted
as a kind of
citizen to the kingdom of grief and made
aware
of how much of this there was around me
to which i had been oblivious close
friends
how and especially now how much loss
people have endured
in the past couple of years
and there's a psychology to loss
um
and
but it's an it's an inarticulate uh
psychology people behave differently
when they've experienced the loss and it
expresses itself in strange ways
i'm just trying personally to navigate
it in my own way so i minimize the
damage it causes i loved her so much i
was so proud to be her dad
she was just the best human being and
she was going to change the world i
can't do anything about the fact she's
gone all i can do is make sure that
what happens
next
isn't worse or bad i can just try to
respond in positive ways to it
i think that
i i cannot speak for other people in
their grief
but
in my case
um
the experience
which
experiences of loss is a loss of love
and leaning into love
in various ways in response to her death
has been enormously healing leaning into
other people's need for love
um
so
it it's
um
the mis the tempting mistake
that
i think we've been avoiding
is denial just on the writing you've
written about finance you've heard about
policy you've written about so many
things do you think now you might write
about grief that that might help other
people grieving
um
yes
i'm not quite sure what form the writing
is going to take
i know it won't take the form of a
how-to
because i do think
i think it's so peculiar the the
experience of grief
is
suey generous that yeah every grief is
grief is grief but it's not each
person's grief is different it depends
on the nature of the loss the nature of
the relationship you had with the person
who's lost who you are how your
chemicals work
so i would be very hard i'd be very wary
about telling people
how to go through this experience except
to say however you're going through it
is fine walk in and embrace what's
peculiar about your own response because
this there's some truth in that now how
i write about it
i've got some ideas about how i might
write about it but it's it's i'm not
going to ever be in a position of
preaching to people
or
how they should experience their own
loss
that wouldn't be my
my style well thank you for talking to
me about it because i'm sure that many
people watching it find it very
comforting because i don't think any of
us talk about grief we don't do lots of
enough we don't do lost
and a lot of people live through it and
find it hard yep so thank you andrew i
thoroughly enjoyed our conversation
thanks for coming on thanks for having
me
well that's all for today's show thank
you to all of our guests michael lewis
dame emma thompson and darryl mccormick
and catherine burbalsing and thank you
for watching
and if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
beth rigby interviews podcast a new
episode's available now each week i take
a look at the highlights of the
interviews and there's some extra bits
and pieces in there too that's on the
sky news app or wherever you get your
podcasts
[Music]
the world seems to be becoming more and
more divided issues around politics
culture the pandemic are resulting in
vastly opposing viewpoints causing real
risks between us
i want to get in the middle of those
debates i want to better understand
where each stance comes from and whether
there's room for compromise
join me trevor phillips as we look to
find common ground on sky news
the plan is to take the political
temperature midweek so we'll be
discussing the biggest stories of the
week so far talking about what's still
to come having a look at prime
minister's questions of course and
getting reaction from politicians plus
our very own viewers and we'll have
analysis from my sky news colleagues the
take with sophie ridge on sky news
[Music]
a
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
i'm ivan bonio i'm a sailor
i spent half time of my life on the on
the sea
we have a factory we can convert this
plastic to energy
and so after at the end we can minimize
the footprint carbon of the boat
[Music]
so
[Music]
you